he sounds absolutely splendid and so i
agree with him we need more young people
involved in politics uh but for now
you're going for liz trust why i am why
because in cabinet liz was the most
supportive cabinet minister in getting
breaks to opportunities
and was
using her role and her chairmanship of
cabinet committees to make sure we could
get the breaks of opportunities through
she also opposed the endless tax rises
of the former chancellor which i think
have been economically damaging i also
was opposed to within cabinet and i
think that's important that you have
somebody who
is fiscally on the right side of the
argument who doesn't believe that higher
taxation is the right answer to every
question
and because i think she's been very good
in leading with the prime minister on
ukraine and making sure we had a strong
response to russia so i think in foreign
policy and domestic policy and european
policies she's got the right answers how
important is loyalty to you extremely
important how long do you think she'd
been campaigning uh planning her
campaign for well i think lots of people
had had
drinks parties with other mps and they
had had um meetings but that's the
routine business of cabinet ministers
even i had drinks parties with other mps
uh when
are they watching for ages no no i don't
think that's right i think that you have
a job as a cabinet minister to meet
other mps so you hear the views of
backbenchers and understand what their
concerns are as leader of the highest
mind were mainly around issues to do
with parliamentary procedure and so on
but the foreign secretary would
naturally have them
with other members of parliament um to
find out what their views were on
foreign policy
i know
that's the assumption that gets made
it's not setting up a website it's not
getting ready in december for a campaign
to come sometime later that's a
different main name quite a long time
that's a different order of magnitude i
have no idea whether she reads the
domain name but
it's
very important that camden ministers
whilst they're in cabinet are loyal i
was as you know and i'm a great
supporter boris johnson and was involved
in his campaign very early on but that
did not happen until he had ceased to be
foreign secretary
um you sailors trust is a strong
brexiteer in fact you were in number 10
with nadine doris saying that she is a
stronger brexiteer than you and nadine
doris put together did she not vote for
remain
i think you need to look at what people
are doing now it is possible for people
to change their mind
so yes of course everyone knows liz
vated for remain but what i was saying
is within cabinets it's very interesting
because when we had a
right round on the retained eu law bill
foreign secretary was completely
supportive about getting rid of the
supremacy of eu law and having a sunset
on eu law
the one of the departments that objected
was the treasury which didn't want tax
policy be taken away from eu
interference so you have a department
led by an ostensible brexiteer that was
backing the supremacy of eu law and a
department led by an ostensible remainer
that was backing ending the supremacy of
eu law i think you have to judge people
by what they do currently um to that end
european convention on human rights even
dominic raab says that he wanted to
remain as part of that whereas liz trust
was saying yesterday i believe that she
thinks that we shouldn't be what do you
think well i think
that there's a bill before parliament at
the moment the
uk bill of rights british bill of rights
which is a sensible way of proceeding
what we need to be able to do
is recognize that the highest form of
law in this country
is law made in parliament that that is
our authoritative law
and that that must be enforced and that
is subject to the greatest of human
rights democratic oversight yeah but the
justice secretary is bringing that
forward and even he has said that he
thinks that we should still remain
within the european community but the
the european convention is not in and of
itself a bad document it is how it is
interpreted and applied and the
ridiculous injunction imposed by the
european court stopping the rwandan
deportations which had been approved by
uk courts uh and had been approved by
the uk parliament is not something that
the uk can carry on putting up with we
have we should come up with we have well
i whether you need to come out of it
formally or whether you can get
derogations is a different matter i
think getting derogations is probably a
simpler way of doing it um nadine doris
who again we saw you with yesterday
accusing rishi sunaka or certainly the
campaign of dirty tricks by lending
votes to jeremy hunt
what do you think i have no idea whether
that's going on uh or not
if it was
well what we need to do is to get two
candidates to the final round um in a
way that the members of the conservative
party can choose i'm strongly in favor
of the
mandate coming from members of the
conservative party
i'm sure that no one would wish to
stitch it up in advance and if they did
i would think that would be improper but
i don't have any evidence that people
are doing that so lending votes would be
inappropriate is how you feel about that
but i'm not making any accusations of
that kind
but you know how it is
with interviews that things can
sometimes get um taken out of context
later so to be absolutely clear i have
no evidence that's going on but if it
were going on it would obviously be
improper um why do you think he's um a
socialist rishi sooner well now you're
referring things that may or may not
have been said in cabinet and i'm glad
to say there's a 30-year rule actually
reduced do you think he is
i think as a chancellor he made
decisions
that were
of the left rather than of the right
that he was a tax increasing chancellor
as i said i didn't support the decisions
he made i thought we should have been
looking at keeping expenditure under
control
rather than raising taxes and i think
the corporation tax rise it's bad for
business bad for investment in the uk
the national insurance hike hits
employers
just after we're getting over the covid
problem and makes life harder for
employees when we're in the midst of a
cost of living crisis i think these were
bad tax rises
so many of the candidates that i've been
speaking to over the last few days are
evoking the memory of margaret thatcher
why are they doing that
well because they think she's a golden
ticket uh with the membership is she um
i think the memory of margaret thatcher
is highly regarded within the
conservative party and certainly by
people like me and i think many of our
members
but people don't always get what
margaret thatcher did
right they have selective memories as to
what she did so i hear somebody has been
saying that
she would not be cutting taxes now the
first thing she did in 1979 when she
became elected they had a budget
straight away which had very significant
cuts in taxation so say margaret thatch
would not have been a tax cut i think
simply wrong but your candidate is even
molding herself in mrs thatcher's image
well margaret thatch was a great lady so
um um a reincarnation of margaret
thatcher uh is i think improbable but
nonetheless that's a very great lady and
of the eight candidates that are left
which of the ones would you not work
with
well it's a democratic process um and uh
the party membership must decide um and
i would remain a loyal backbencher
whoever
was elected i believe in conservatism
i'm talking about particularly about
cabinet post
would you accept a cabinet post from
rishi sooner no of course i wouldn't i
believe his
behavior towards boris johnson his
disloyalty means that i could not
possibly support him um and he wouldn't
want me in his cabinet anyway so it's
entirely mutual oh i'm sure it is yes i
don't think there'd be any question of
him wanting me in his cabinet but i
couldn't support somebody who has been
so disloyal to the current leader of the
party
from inside cabinet and that's that's so
important
um
tom tuggenheart and jeremy hand have
behaved perfectly properly they were
entitled from outside cabinet to make it
clear that they didn't want boris
johnson to continue as prime minister
that that is
a reasonable thing to do but if you're
bound by collective responsibility
you should stick to that um whilst
you're in the cabinet if you don't like
the prime minister if you think he
should be replaced
nadim
sent his letter in when he thought the
writing was on the wall and it was just
a recognition
of the reality that was a matter of
judgment very late in the day we're
almost out of time and sadie javi
deserved his bloody nose then did he
look mostaj is a very decent chap he put
out an excellent document
on the economy really very strong one um
he's fallen out i don't wish to say
disobliging things about um sajid but he
behaved in the same way rishi soon did i
spoke to him yesterday and said i
couldn't possibly support him on the
same basis good to talk to you thank you
very much always a pleasure always a
pleasure bit early in the morning but
none of that
welcome to my world i know i admire your
stamina well you're very kind thank you
very much indeed